Lindsay Lohan turns 30 the actress  celebrated the milestone with friends  and fiance Igor Tarasov in Mykonos  Greece over the weekend it's my 30th  birthday birthday bash included  traditional Greek plate smashing dancing  on tables and a ton of PDA from Lindsay  and her 22 year old beau the mean girl  stars man even gave an adorable speech  in honor of his lady love which her BFF  Julie shared on snapchat Lindsay human  get one for dating a famous friends of  the now 30 year old also made videos  wishing her well  the birthday girls stunned in a sparkly  fringe Celia Chris riadi dress and  shared her thanks with fans on the  designers Instagram page I just wanted  to say I appreciate all the people that  have supported me over the years um can  go up happy 30th Lindsey  you